This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, this is season five
episode 44 of The Chris Abraham
Show and I am just basically
doing a an ad hoc episode where
I admit that I'm a terrible.
Advocate for anything.
Because the more bizarre the
world becomes, the more I'm
interested in seeing how much
more bizarre it can become.
So it's actually actually the
way I live my life is sadly, Go
ahead, Go ahead.
I challenge you.
It's like, it's like that scene
in West Wing where what's his
name is yelling and baiting God,
like, is that all you got?
Is that all you got?
President, president, president.
What's his name?
And I'm like you guys are
telling me that.
That the end is not, you're
telling me that they're going to
make internal combustion engine
illegal and they're going to
outlaw like gas stoves and
they're going to make
motorcycles illegal and they're
going to make owning property
legal and they're going to quote
whop us with another lockdown.
Who's going to be?
Climate lockdown, or the world
is so hot, or the river is
boiling, or all these other
things I'm the worst person to
depend upon for wanting change,
because the only thing I care
about is that people get fed and
people get housed, and people
are treated with kindness no
matter who they are.
Like, no punching Nazis, no
punching fascists, in the same
way that there's no punching
trans people and no punching gay
people, and no punching black
people and no punching Asian
people and no punching, no
punching trumpies and no
punching anybody, right.
Equally not a Punch Fascist or
Punch Nazis thing like everybody
has to be.
Given the compassion and
kindness and love otherwise
you'll just reinforce behavior.
A a beat dog ends up biting A
and and hurt people hurt people.
So the more you can bring people
into the fold and love on people
not beaten switch, but literally
love on people, the better.
So outside of just wanting
people to make sure that they're
fed.
Treated kindly, have a place to
sleep and that's it.
Food, water, shelter.
As long as that is taken care of
and I care about it, you know,
think globally, act locally.
I erase the think globally
because I constantly every day
recite the.
Serenity prayer to myself, which
is God, grant me the serenity to
fix the things I can change and
the wisdom and not fix the
things I can't change and the
wisdom to know the difference.
Or God, grant me the serenity to
accept the things that I can't
change, change the things that I
can.
And the wisdom to know the
difference.
Amen.
Or something like that.
So like the thought of my head
doesn't have to be exact.
Like I say to myself, how much
control do I have over this, or
how much of my energy towards
fretting or worrying about the
end is nigh?
Like how much of it is do I have
any remote control over right?
Hey, Howdy.
Hey, how's, how's your luck
going?
Good.
Pretty good.
Solid run.
Nothing crazy.
Well, I didn't win the.
I didn't win the lottery again.
So you're doing better than me.
But when I come here with
wearing a a mink stole or a
sable coat, you'll know that I
finally hit the lottery.
All right, that's good to know.
See you at the library or at or
at Starbucks.
Have a good day.
Anyway, the wisdom to know the
difference is different, right?
Like all y'all see me on social
media, trolling and so forth.
But I feel like a lot of all
y'all's energy is like spent on
things that don't remotely
affect you or me.
Like I live a small life.
Like I I got rid of all my
vehicles until I got skinny
again, because I tend to always
throw, in fact.
I've stopped using those E bikes
because I found myself using
them as crutches.
I haven't used an E bike in
three weeks because I I realized
that I was using E bikes all the
time and and when I really
wanted to ride E bikes all the
time, they were everywhere.
And now that I don't want to use
E bikes, they're nowhere.
Which is to say that we live in
a simulation.
And the more that people can
convince you that crazy shit is
happening, the more that those
things can be manifested into
reality.
So I'm that kind of hippie.
Do you ever wonder what what,
what what flavor of weirdo I am?
I believe that that the
concerted wishes of a large
number of people, no matter
whether it's for.
The honoring and adoration of
God or for a crazy obsession
that the water's boiling.
I dare say that who needs harp?
Who needs harp?
Or or or weather satellites or
any other kind of things that
the Chinese admit that they had
during the Chinese Olympics.
I believe that the will of
people, whether it's done in
meditation and prayer.
Or just by putting things, I
think tweets are like little
prayers, right?
If you get people to constantly
obsess over trans rights or
Asian rights or L GB TQIA rights
or or equity versus equality and
justice for thee, but not for
me.
Justice for me, but not for
thee.
Freedom for thee, but not for
me.
Freedom for me, but not for
thee.
If you play all those games and
if you come across as a big fat
hypocrite where you want all
your rights but you don't want
people who you call
irresponsible to have their
rights while they're saying, why
would anybody with blue hair be
responsible for for deciding
whether or not I speak my truth?
And then?
This noble obligation of people
feeling like they have the
ability to decide if someone
else is saying something that
might affect someone else in a
bad way.
It's like if my mom knew that I
was going to talk stink about
the The Dirty laundry.
In my my in my mom's family, in
my dad's family closets.
Then she would create a law that
would prevent me from talking
about dirty laundry in my
parents and grandparents
closets, saying things like
we're preventing that for
national security, which is
national national secrecy, which
is she just is would be too
embarrassed that the truth got
out.
And there might be real
ramifications of things you have
to pay for, right?
That's exactly why freedom of
speech is so important.
It is like the sun.
It is.
And whenever, like people really
care about open kimono or or the
OR, sunlight is the best
disinfectant, except when it's
their own stink, right?
Like people were plenty happy.
Making spurious cases out of
nowhere just to impeach Trump.
But when people use the same
strategy, which is spurious
cases, to impeach Biden, then
you got to know that that the
entire world is a a petty, a
petty tweenager.
The entire world works just like
middle school.
I'm surprised, I mean.
Who doesn't think that the
Republicans are maybe more
mature than the Democrats?
Because honestly, Biden hasn't
been impeached four times yet,
so none of these accusations.
The accusations of Trump over
January 6 was, which was
spurious.
January 6th, January 6th was
It's all.
Hyperbole to get us all ginned
up.
And since you all do not have
advantasia, you all are like
madly visualizing terrible
things.
And no matter how much Rustic
Gate is debunked, or no matter
how much we end up finding out
that.
You know, all the acquit of all
the accusations against Trump
and all the indictments and so
forth don't end up, don't end up
with him in jail and end up
being completely overturned by
the Supreme Court.
It doesn't matter.
Like people will just remember
that Trump was impeached 12
times.
By the way, he was never kicked
out of office.
Trump was indicted 75 times.
By the way, he was never
convicted.
Trump was was civilly sued 255
times and never was.
Never resulted in in anything
negative, and it was all just
settled or thrown out of court
or not accepted in court anyway.
So that's what's going on.
I'm just watching with a
terrible desire to see how crazy
it actually gets.
Like words are one thing.
And I expected to be thrown into
a FEMA camp by now.
Or reeducation camp.
Or I expected to go into.
I expected to.
I don't know.
The world was over.
I expected nuclear war before,
you know, not long after 1988.
I totally expected nuclear war,
right?
Why not so?
Unless I actually see stuff
happen with my own eyes, I
assume that God doesn't exist.
I assume that UF O's don't
exist.
I assume that Sasquatch doesn't
I assume that I don't even, you
know, I don't like, I don't even
know, truly if Ukraine war is
happening or if World War 2
happened the way it was told or
or.
You know whether this is just an
elaborate.
Wag the dog strategy because we
are small people who live in
small places and we receive the
various and sundry news from TV
production studios and we know
that TV production studios have
relaborate ability to make very
convincing movies and films and
TV shows.
So once I see.
The actual world completely
falling apart, first person,
then I'm just going to assume
that it's it's just, it's just
what is it Smellivision, it's 3D
Smellivision, and they're all
just storytelling via the media
channels.
When I went around the world,
everybody was nice, Everybody
was.
Gentle Everybody was loving.
Everybody went out of their way
to be kind to me.
Everywhere I've ever been,
people have been kind to me.
I haven't been kidnapped or
carjacked or or punched in the
face.
The only violence I've ever been
embedded in are violence.
Events that I've that I've been
the victor because I'm
preemptive and violent.
And cruel.
And I do not hesitate because
I'm always afraid of someone
punching out the teeth that my
mom spent thousands of dollars
fixing with the orthodentist,
orthodontics, orthodentist,
ortho, blah blah blah.
So that's it.
I'm a terrible advocate because
I don't believe anything anybody
tells me.
I believe it's all psyops.
I believe it's all hearts and
minds.
I believe it's all the fog of
war.
I believe it's all wag the dog.
I believe that it's all being
there with Peter Sellers.
I believe that it's a grant.
I believe that the world is
WWEI, believe that Donald Trump
is the heel and Joe Biden is the
face.
And I believe that.
Everything's going to be all
right.
Anyway.
I love you guys.
I hope you have fun.
I hope you enjoy this.
I'll call this a special
episode.
Mahalo,
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.